y a pas d'image de violences policières
il ya une scène où un policier dans
l'action à un moment d'une charge a
effectivement poussé quelqu'un pour y
voir clair nous avons fait le choix
oui mais dans la confrontation vous
savez quand les policiers sont chargés
de dégager une manifestation
effectivement il y à des gestes qui
peuvent se produire mais pour lever le
doute y compris parce que ce qui nous
est rapportée c'est que l'individu en
question voulait se saisir d'une grenade
et pour la renvoyer sur les forces de
l'ordre
j'ai demandé au préfet que l'inspection
générale de la police nationale soit
saisie aime ça et madame peut pas d'un
côté critiqué tous gestes de chacun des
policiers de france qui sont confrontés
à des violences et ne pas parler de ce
policier qui est toujours en réanimation
est toujours en réanimation depuis dix
jours après être tombé sur la place de
la république
je pense qu'il faut aussi d'un côté ne
pas se contenter de remercier les forces
de l'ordre quand tout va bien et la
faire des procès et des procès
d'intention à tout va ma règle est
simple chaque fois qu'il ya un
signalement d'un fait qui peut semer le
doute
je souhaite que l'inspection générale de
la police nationale sous l'autorité du
parquet sous une autorité judiciaire
puisse mener l enquête